my name is Tim bolt citizen journalist
and I just took on the biggest threat to
America
the FBI Russian hopes not deep state FBI
wishing it is not the same as I wish
they would let Trump Baga I wish they
would drop this Russia hoax so that he
could maka I want an Imagi probably
wondering why I'm interrogating a former
FBI agent well I've turned the tables
because the FBI has been smearing our
great leader but first let's rewind a
bit the FBI is investigating Trump's
ties to Russia during the 2016 election
so I sat down with Frank Montoya jr. who
coincidentally has the most FBI sounding
name I've ever heard he's also the
former FBI head of national
counterintelligence executive now this
outspoken hotshot has been attacking
America's most valuable asset president
Trump's feelings
luckily Trump wasn't taking this sitting
down he's been going on almost daily
Twitter rampages to undermine the
credibility of this rogue American law
enforcement agency we're the good guys
why attack us and say nary a negative
thing about Putin or about the Russian
interference why call it a witch-hunt
Comey and Muller are clearly lifelong
leftists that have been in a sleeper
cell waiting to take down Donald J Trump
all connected by red circles and lines
where did those circles and lines come
from trick question I used this red
marker to draw them myself
I wish it were so simple but no if we
were to talk about that I know that both
of these men were appointed by
Republican presidents it is that simple
okay
Muller and Comey and ray and Rosenstein
and a bunch more are all known
Republicans but they're not acting like
Republicans anymore and that's what
Trump is trying to expose well it's a
shame what's happened with the FBI when
you look at what's gone on with the FBI
and with the Justice Department people
are very very angry
don't FBI people find it motivating to
be repeatedly assaulted know guys that
are just doing their jobs that have are
sworn to uphold and defend the
Constitution or getting dragged to the
mud for no other purpose than partisan
political benefit the fact is it it
undermines what we're trying to do
across the board whether it is
counterterrorism or it is
counterintelligence or it's in working
with our local state and police partners
what you just said is both care to
comment you know the Democrats do want
to comment on the steel dossier the
so-called steel gaw steel dossier steel
dossier 35 pages that allege ties
between a Trump campaign and Russia
allegations of Russian collusion and
other lies all of them disgusting lies
lies lies lies I wouldn't call them lies
at this point in time it came from a
reliable source
the fact of the matter is dirt is dirt
and there are charges that have been
brought because individuals were
breaking the law can I ask you to be a
hundred percent honest with me certainly
look me in the eyes and tell me
do you think the P tape is real you know
there's always that possibility that's
right the P tape P tape the PTFE tape
the liberal obsession within the steel
dossier that's become the less number
one perverted fantasy about drama
I want to rush on business I love it
there and I especially love the
prostitutes on Donna
- like high-powered businessman yes I do
good call a prostitute friends
told her to bring over a bunch of
bottles of water I wanna fill the
bladders Obama stayed here once I want
to use the tile at the Bama used no you
pee on the bed the bad world bomb was
slept
I hate Obama so much I can't it comes to
pee Oh someone's been recording the
screen and still being I hope no one
tries to blackmail me with this yeah
that's exactly what gets them off
and I mean sure Putin has blackmailed
politicians with sex tapes in the past
but he'd never do that to Trump they're
buddies it's probably a not a red
herring but the least of our troubles
you're saying that the P tape is real
but it doesn't matter I don't think that
that's a violation of the law in Russia
but money laundering is structuring
financial dealings are there are other
areas that should require investigative
focus what we saw the Russian to do was
pretty mind-blowing I have seen a lot of
espionage operations over the years
nothing of this magnitude directed at
the United States of America Russia is
not gonna stop unless we are united in
our effort to try and stop it
not to go I'll Tucker Carlson on you but
I don't understand Frank had done his
best to fill my head with bogus FBI
talking points but I hadn't fallen for
any of it of course there were a couple
things he'd said working good Putin
espionage money laundering
Russia is not gonna stops not gonna
stops not gonna stop home
yes I'm gonna learn stairway